business agility is about consuming
services and applications with more and
more sas and services being consumed you
don't have to reinvent the wheel to be
productive
google cloud private service connect is
the solution to help you accelerate your
consumption of these services in the
cloud securely simply and quickly stay
tuned
[Music]
services like erp sas applications
database as a service financial data
sets log analytics and file sharing have
increasingly enabled companies to stay
ahead that trend and the migration to
cloud will only continue for enterprises
but diverse services means more
complexity services all live in
different networks and environments
application developers want to simply
connect to and consume each service
rather than spend time tinkering with
routing tables ip addresses and nat
rules
in addition security has only become
more fundamental to all aspects of
company operations most companies have
requirements to restrict traffic to
private networks not allowing public ips
in order to reduce vulnerabilities
google cloud private service connect
vastly simplifies service connectivity
so you can consume services quickly with
minimal management it's a fully managed
solution
it lets you set up
private connectivity to your own third
party and google services across
networks that belong to different groups
teams projects or organizations if
you're trying to set up connectivity for
a workload to consume data from services
like a gke private master cloud spanner
cloud storage or a financial data set on
a private network psc lets you simply
set up an endpoint from your network and
a target service
if you want to expose a service like a
log streaming application to be
discoverable you simply set up a service
attachment
private service connect enables service
centric networking by creating an
abstraction layer on top of our
traditional network capabilities to make
the network completely transparent it
helps you consume services faster
achieve a service driven environment
secure your data and simplify network
management
private service connect is secure
traffic doesn't traverse a public
internet your services interact like
they're on their own private network
simple and performant it takes care of
network configuration so you don't have
to worry about routing tables ip
addresses and unnecessary coordination
between teams you don't need to
configure proxies in your network and it
provides line rate performance
agile it lets you focus on the service
instead of network management so dev
teams are empowered to easily set up
connectivity on their own unburdening
network engineering teams both teams can
independently get up and running and be
more productive
for the demo today i already created all
the networking resources instances
internal load balancer and cloud storage
bucket represented in this diagram for
simplicity
we're going to show how a client in the
consumer vpc can access a new service in
the producer vpc through a private
service connect endpoint and service
attachment
when the client sends traffic from its
source ip to the endpoint the private
service connect will send the allowed
traffic from the client ip to another
address in the producer subnet where the
private service connect service
attachment is then to the internal load
balancer forwarding rule to forward
traffic to the backend servers
i'll then show the client also accessing
a google api a cloud storage bucket
through another private service connect
endpoint
i'll start with the producer vpc with
two subnets 1002 is the producer subnet
that hosts our web servers then the psc
subnet gives access from the consumer
network to producer services being
exposed to show you the routes i can
verify that there is no connectivity
from the consumer vpc to the producer
vpc just a default route to the internet
i only have firewall rules that allow
traffic from those two subnets plus the
health check ranges to make sure my
service is healthy
now if i head over to private service
connect
and then the publish services tab
i can see the psc producer service
it's configured to automatically accept
all projects and staging dash web is my
consumer project already connected
this exposed service is the load
balancer as a backend with a private ip
of 100210
and if front ends are web server
instances which is the service we're
exposing
now i'll show my consumer vpc with a
single subnet and different private ip
and i also have no firewall rules set up
here on the consumer side
under routes there's nothing but the
subnet route i deleted the default route
to the internet to show private service
connect enabling connection to google
apis in this case our storage bucket
under private service connect you can
see here there's two connected endpoints
the pse-consumer endpoint targets the
web servers we have on the producer vpc
this endpoint ends in dot 100 the psc ga
endpoint targets all google apis this
endpoint ends in 0.111
when the pscga endpoint was created it
also created a new dns private zone with
dns name
p.googleapis.com it doesn't create any
records but you can now use private
service connect to target google apis
using this domain and you get automatic
dns resolution
next i'll navigate to the consumer
client vm with only an internal ip and
i'll ssh into it using cloud shell
to show the client using private service
connect to reach the web servers in the
producer vpc i'll run a curl command to
the web server in the producer vpc
subnet using its local endpoint ending
in dot 100
and i can see i can access the server
now let's provide connectivity to google
apis with private service connect i can
query our storage bucket using the
private service connect endpoint pscga
by doing an ns lookup for storage dash
the psc endpointname.p.googleapis.com
and it returns the pscga endpoint
ip100.111
i also have my gsutil client configured
to use this private endpoint and now i
can list the bucket content just to
prove that's the content if i navigate
to the consumer psc bucket page in the
console it's the same file going back to
the consumer vpc's firewall rules page
you can see the psc-subnet rule now has
a hit count of 1 because the session i
just established
the connectivity between the client vm
and producer backends and the storage
bucket isn't explicit
but it's enabled by private service
connect it happens privately and
securely through google's backbone
network
with private service connect you can
consume services faster and stay ahead
of the curve because it's a fully
managed solution meet compliance and
keep traffic secure
simplify your network and move to the
cloud faster
leverage a strong and growing list of
third party vendors and partners
and get performance and scale to keep up
with your growth and the competition
check out cloud.google.com
privateserviceconnect to learn more and
check out the links below for codelabs
and guide and remember optimizing your
network means freeing up your bandwidth
[Music]
you